The question is where did this number come from? How did we get at 85%?
To calculate percent error is a pretty straightforward calculation.
All we do is look at the absolute error.
In this case, the absolute error was Plato's guess, 74,000,
minus the actual circumference of the earth, 40,000.
We'd look at this absolute error, and we'd divide by the true circumference.
In this case, 40,000 km.
When I do this, I get 74,000 - 40,000, so 34,000/40,000.
The absolute error over the known circumference.
We can see we can do some cancelling.
We're left with 34/40, which reduces to 17/20 or 85%.
Now, this is something we'll be doing quite frequently in this class
when we want to talk about error.
Now, Plato wasn't the only person to make a guess about the circumference of the earth.
After Plato, another famous and brilliant thinker made a guess at the circumference of the earth.
That was Archimedes.
Now, Archimedes guessed that the earth had a circumference of 300,000 stadia.
I want you to tell me how far off was Archimedes.
What was his percent error?  You can enter your number here,
and you don't need to include the percent sign.
Some additional information you may need to use to make this calculation
is that the true circumference of the earth is 40,000 km.
One stadium is 185 m, and 1 km is 1,000 meters.
Enter your answer here.